it's funny because my kids have like
favorite colors and me as a 37 year old
man
should not have a favorite color but i
really like this color
welcome to diesel's merrell's 10
essentials
that's right we're sitting down with gq
to tell you what we need to get through
our day
so we got five from me and five from d
[Music]
i was told that i could do this in any
order that i want but i
am a very serious structured individual
so i'm doing it chronologically and
chronologically
one of my first essentials is a rail
of cafe bustelo you know what i'm saying
this is incredible this
this will power you through the entire
day with no food whatsoever
i was six years old in dominican
republic drinking this with a loaf of
bread and i would pick 85 mangoes in a
minute
and people like you were drinking
espresso at six years old i was like yes
i'm culture and then you need a downer
like around lunchtime
this is when this guy comes out a little
dominican rum
throw a little in your arnold palmer
with your reuben sandwich you know what
i mean and get a little loose
loosey-goosey for the rest of the day
you know what i'm saying it helps me
deal with my four children
that are constantly attacking me they
wake me up by jumping on my genitals
before they demand that i turn on all
video game systems so they can play
fortnite simultaneously my house sounds
like a [ __ ] green girl
when do you remember like your first
time drinking that my first time
drinking brugal
uh dominican rum uh was in the dominican
republic
like as a teen and i was just like wow i
really want to fight and have sex at the
same time
and it has that effect to this day i'm a
37 year old man and i drink that stuff
and i want to have
vigorous intercourse with my wife and or
fight somebody shirtless on the street
you know she boy jesus knights here's my
first gq essential
if you watch the show you'll see me pour
it in pounds and gallons of becks every
episode
but now that i'm trying to get healthy
and i'm at home it's not cool to be
drunk in the middle of the afternoon
especially if you're recording from a
closet inside your house so my first
essential
pressed juice challenge to the homies
add juice press the kale apple ginger
lemon pineapple pressed juice it's like
ten dollars but it's worth it it's like
getting a meal
and it keeps you healthy and then also
because you're drinking pressed juice
you can look your nose down on other
people like oh you're not trying to get
healthy like me
i pity you but yeah i rocks with this
green juice
and listen for flavor
can't go wrong with that can't go wrong
with that it's it's like licking the
butt of kale
so it's good for you boom
another essential for me airpods and
these are the airpod pro
you know what i mean because a regular
airpod they're not noise cancelling and
like i said before
my house sounds like [ __ ] guy's a
strip you know what i mean because all
my kids are playing fortnite at the same
time so
to cancel out the noise and to perform
at optimal quality
when we're doing the number one show
late night these romero
these are super duper duper essential
they cancel
noise my wife is probably yelling at me
right now i don't even know what she's
talking about
how dirty is the case oh i don't even
want to show you this case is
filthy look at the inside of this it's
so gross i'm like embarrassed i'm
i'm legit embarrassed right now there's
like there might be earwax in there
you know what i'm saying i just that's
why i did it super fast but i know you
people are trash you know what i mean
and you're going to
do a screen grab of like the exact
moment where you can see the most earwax
possible and be like ew
[Applause]
hey you know what i'm dirty but i'm on
tv so [ __ ] you
all right this is what you got next
my second essential because now we're
working from home uh
shout out to candace our makeup lady we
no longer have the honor
of having her visit us and make us
beautiful before we go into these zoom
cocoons as i like to call them
so my second essential would be this is
grown
alchemist detox serum antioxidant plus
three complex it's a facial oil
and i use it for under the eyes and use
it for the
my t-zones before we record and if you
put it on
the night before it makes your skin less
oily and you don't get the dry patches
and it comes out well when you record on
zoom because you know if you're doing a
gq interview you want to look like you
just woke up so you want to put a little
antioxidant in there
get a good shine look at my skin so
that's why i recommend anti-oxidant
facial oil boom that's my second
essential right there
another essential listen when you're
married father four
a lot of the times you want to do the
married man thing
of escaping your family via the bathroom
you know what i'm saying and the way you
do that is you take a book with you
and this is the book that you will read
and i am not just saying that because i
wrote it you know what i mean this is a
very good book
and it's perfect for like whatever time
you need
to escape on the toilet it could be five
minutes it could be 10 minutes it could
be 50 minutes
there is a chapter in this book that
aligns with your dumb
and so buy this right now also it's 200
pages long
so there's so many shits in this book
like you could escape for hours bro you
could like go in the book
you could just go in the bathroom for
like a month read books
read all right for my third essentials
it's very cheap
but it's a lifesaver it's a game changer
it's a blackout face mask
it covers your eyes when you sleep i
didn't realize the importance of this
until you're like the pandemic struck
and you're going to bed at 7am even
though you got a 9 am zoom
like no you need some sleep this is a
game change this is like blackout
curtains for your eyes
it's like when you go into a hotel and
you've got those heavy curtains it's
lights out
and you get these anywhere they're
usually at the checkout counter at like
your local pharmacy you don't even have
to go to like sharper image or some
weird place to get there
get these these will change how you
sleep i swear by them i swear
these are the m zoos these ones are
really
well made if you look at the padding
right here they look they look like a
bra for your eyes
how great is that you know what i'm
saying they're just gonna cup your eyes
you
you go to sleep bro you're dead to the
world doesn't get better than that
after a long day i like to unwind a
little bit you know what i'm saying and
i like to play video games you know what
i'm saying i enjoy a little video game
here and there
and lately this has been an essential
for me this is a nintendo switch
light it's not as big as the like
original switch which makes it cool
because
i could just like throw this in my back
pocket and if i'm like sitting in a
waiting room at the dentist or some [ __ ]
and i don't want to talk to anybody and
i'm high i can just put on sunglasses
and a mask and play super smash brothers
on this for two hours
while i'm in the waiting room and nobody
knows og link
is my guy you know what i mean with the
little spinning helicopter
sword attack thing that's that's my dude
also
it has like wi-fi and uh i'm not sure
if i can watch porn on it yet
but i'll find out
all right so my fourth gq essential this
is a five blade razor you can shave your
head with it
and some of y'all like jesus you wear
hats all the time look at this
see this see this no more barbershop
baby you get this i got this from amazon
look at the numbers you see the numbers
on it
99 you can give yourself a haircut every
day
for like 10 it takes like 10 minutes you
can shave your head completely bored
is a pandemic you're not going back to a
barber shop unless you're really trying
to get the rona
because you know what it is you get a
haircut you you super sexy for 48 hours
and then your powers start leveling off
the hair starts coming back in different
areas
it's not fully grown uh if you were
going bald you might get that
kind of weird clown thing where you have
hair in the back but it's looking like a
honey bun in the front
so with this turn it on whisk with swiss
little circles
it's like you just left the barbershop
you go on amazon and get one you would
think these are super expensive
this was like 25 get one of these usb
chargeable
listen it is a game changer you're gonna
be super sexy and as we all know
towards the end of our lives we all end
up bored like michael jordan get on the
ball now all right
jesus recommends this one
i saved the best for last this is
actually like a combo item
because there's five items in this item
special pieces of my heart
it is my family let's get a close-up in
there you know what i'm saying look at
this drip
that's my christmas card who on earth
has a christmas card this
drippy i do not know i do not care
there's no comparison you know i'm
saying so shout out to
me first and foremost for having the
drip shout out to my wife heather
supermom
super wife super everything my lovely
daughter azalea
my eldest son adrian who is a genius
my middle son avery who is
the next rajon rondo and omari
who maybe you know the nfl because he
really likes football you know what i'm
saying he really likes to knock it down
again these are my children but they
also are investments and i want
good roi and also like the reason
why these guys are so essential to me is
that they keep me humble so
shout out to them because without them i
would not be as motivated to do
everything that i do
[Music]
my fifth and most essential essential
essential thing i need right now if
y'all have if y'all working out in the
quarantine
and you know i'm saying y'all might want
a foam roller y'all might want to
stretch
no listen i've worked hard and i watch
out to live vicariously through diesels
so my fifth final thing boom bang bang
you see it right here
it is the thera gun this is the game
changer
if you work out you want to take this
bad boy and put it to your muscles
if you got charlie horses you got kinks
in your back you turn on this bad boy
it feels like like kindergartners are
punching you in your kidneys it's one of
the most amazing feelings ever
this will have you doing activities you
have no business doing trust me the
first time you use it it's going to pay
for itself so terror gun thank you you
you're keeping me limp out here and how
much is it again
i want to say it's like between four
and six hundred dollars but i mean you
could write it off i guess or shoplift
it
it's up to you get it how you get it all
right this is the pandemic get it sent
to
your neighbor and then swipe it from the
package rule don't never know thank you
for watching those were our essentials
yo we out europe
thank you to gq i'll see you on the flip
side y'all